International forces in Mali have been trying
to help fight Islamist groups which in 2012
threatened to take over the whole country.
Nearly ten years and over 10 billion euros
of international funding later, huge swathes of
the country are still out of government control.
The UN has peacekeepers there, and EU troops
also train local soldiers. DW's West Africa
correspondent Fred Muvunyi went to Koulikoro –
just outside the capital Bamako for this report.
Malian soldiers learn about Improvised Explosive
Devices - how to find them, how to defuse them.
IEDs are a plague in places like
Mali – effectively home-made mines,
which kill soldiers and civilians alike.
Germany is leading the training mission
on behalf of the EU. The trainers
are confident things are improving.
The Europeans may be able to give Malians western
technical know-how. But Malian forces still
operate firmly in an autocratic environment.
We wanted to hear from a Malian soldier,
but a local commander told us this was
absolutely forbidden. We understood that
a soldier could be physically harmed if they
were to break ranks and talk to the media.
"International forces like these have been here
in Mali for years - trying to help the government
fight jihadist groups. Foreign governments have
poured money as well as sending soldiers to
try to build solid local security forces.
But the jihadists are not pulling back."
The violence has forced many Malians to leave
their villages and seek refuge here in the
capital, Bamako. It’s created a mix of people,
all hoping *someone* will stop the fighting.
"The international community should let
the transition government do its job."
"We need the international to extend its
support. So that we get out of this crisis."
"To take Mali out of this problem,
poor economy, and insecurity, we
need France to leave this country"
The EU mission still has three years of its
mandate to run. They still have much to do,
to enable Malian forces to defend the government
against the Islamists - from the air as well as
on the ground. These soldiers are learning
to call in air strikes accurately.
"They need to study a lot of topography because
they need to be precise when they go on the
ground. We are talking about an aircraft attacking
on the ground, so we need to be precise about what
we are saying and the coordinates we brought on
the map. We need to avoid the collateral damages."
The Malian air force is still very small –
a few attack planes, some helicopters and
one cargo plane. They’re training for a future
when they’ll be taking on their enemy alone.